hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts and keynote presentation
the dynamics of the unconscious brain
under general anaesthesia presented by
dr. Embry and Browne Warren Anza Pole
professor of anesthesia Harvard Medical
School professor of computational
neuroscience MIT director neural science
statistics research laboratory and the
CSIs Massachusetts General I'm Alexis
Krause of laberd's and I will be your
moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
laberd's laborat is the leading
scientific social networking website
introduce our educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
question into the drop down box that
appears on your screen
dr. Brown will be responding to your
questions via email if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the help desk button
located and the promotional board at the
bottom center of your screen or use the
ask a question box to let us know that
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
June of 2018 please join me in welcoming
dr. Anne Marie and brown I will now turn
the presentation over to him so today
what I'm going to talk about is what
happens to the brain under anesthesia
and I've entitled this talk decipher the
dynamics of the unconscious brain under
general anesthesia
I'm Emery Brown I'm a professor of
anesthesia at National Hospital Harvard
Medical School and also professor of
computational neuroscience and medical
engineering here at MIT and so today
what I'm going to do is take you through
a little bit of the work that we've done
to try to understand what happens to the
under anesthesia so here's the outline
I'm gonna follow we're going to first
just take a quick clinical look at what
happens under general anesthesia then
I'm going to speak specifically about
loss of consciousness by the drugs
propofol and I'll go over a couple of
other anaesthetic anesthetics as well
then I'll say something about what
happens to the response to anesthesia as
we get older the aging brain and then
finally I want to leave you with some
ideas for the future which I'll call
reanimation from general anesthesia
you'll see what that means when we get
to that so let me just tell you the
punch lines right here before we start
so general anesthesia regardless of how
you think about it now the brain is not
turned off it's actually dynamic and one
of the main things is the brain the
states are created by the circuits in
the brain generating oscillations the
juggs dry them into these oscillations
and we think that this is one of the
primary ways to which the drugs produce
these altered states of arousal by
inducing and sustaining these
oscillations these oscillations are so
large they're readily visible an
electroencephalogram they change
systematic with age of the patient and
also dose of the drug therefore provides
a very straightforward way of monitoring
the brains of patients receiving general
anesthesia and finally what I want to
leave you with as I mentioned earlier is
a way to turn the brain back on right
now what we do is we let the anesthetic
drugs wear off but perhaps one of the
ways that we can reduce brain
dysfunction following anesthesia and
surgery and speeding recovery is by
turning the brain back on right so and
the the final thought that I want to
leave you with is that we're studying
anesthesia for the sake of improving
patient care for for those who need
surgery but as I hope you'll get a sense
of this is also a way of studying the
brain and I would argue that's a
paradigm which to date has been
underutilized so what is general
anesthesia so it's a drug induced
reversible state consisting of
unconsciousness and these you're not
supposed to remember analgesia it's not
supposed to hurt a kinesia it's helpful
if you're not moving around well the
surgeons are operating so if you take
the first for these first four
conditions
and you take out the word reversible in
the first sentence then they'd be
synonymous with death and on that list
of things which is not cool that's
certainly very high up there so we
create a reversible state and if you
look down here at the bottom you see it
says you have stability and control the
physiological systems so we put you in
this state we maintain control of your
heart rate blood pressure temperature
your stress responses and then we bring
you out now I've put the sentence there
it says it's not clear how anesthetics
work and what I want to give you a sense
of is just with a few kind of empirical
looks from the beginning that that's not
the case and hopefully by the end of
this you'll appreciate that a lot is
actually known how general anesthesia is
produced so but before I do that let me
just tell you practically what we do
when we take care of patients in the
operating room and this is what we call
balanced general anesthesia so we use
different classes of drugs to create the
states of anesthesia so if you look here
where we start with amnesia we can give
you drugs which will make it difficult
for you to form memories benzodiazepines
like valium like drugs or the hypnotic
switch would be a drug like propofol or
the inhaled drugs the inhaled drugs
which we currently still use our ethers
they've we've changed their chemical
structure a bit but they're still just
modern-day ethers for pain we primarily
use opioids although the inhaled drugs
would work as well and to create the
state of unconsciousness we use
barbiturates propofol propofol is
probably the most used anesthetic and
again the inhale drugs and then for
immobility
in order to make it so that you are not
moving while the surgeons are operating
will actually give you a drug which
relaxes your muscles they're primarily
anticholinergics they block the
cholinergic transmission at the where
the nerves intersect the muscles but the
inhaled drugs do that as well so you can
basically see that the inhaled drugs is
in each one of the categories and so
this is where the idea of balanced
anesthesia comes about I could use one
drug and achieve all of these but at the
cost of having tremendous side-effects
so the benefit of using multiple
different drugs to create the same state
as we get mostly all the good effects of
those drugs let's say the opioids and
the Creedy analgesia and fewer the side
effects by just using a single drug
right and then we also administer drugs
to maintain stability and the integrity
of the human dynamic system so in order
to make this a bit more concrete I'm
going to play a little video for you
here which is a the video of the
electroencephalogram the EEG the
brainwaves of a woman who whom I took
care of about well it's been about four
and a half years ago now so she's 60
years old she's coming to have surgery
and on all in all of our operating rooms
in mastering our hospital we have a eg
so we can measure the brainwaves of
patients who are receiving anesthesia
and as I'm going to show you we can use
this to track the states of the patients
while they're receiving while while
they're under while they're under
anesthesia and so there are four leads
here they're two up at the two on the
left two on the right and their mark
their l1r 1r L 2 R 2 and this is just
going to be a standard induction this
isn't edited at all for time or anything
I'm gonna give her a bolus dose of
propofol about 150 milligrams and I'm
going to explain to you what happens to
her as this transpires so I'm gonna
start the video now and I'll just take
you through the various parts of it so
if you've never have seen EEG before
those are eye blinks you can see there
across all the leads they're very large
artifacts that occur when patients move
their eyes and what you're going to see
in just a second here is a lot of noise
appearing right and the reason this
noise appears is that if if you inject
propofol into a vein like a small vein
on the back of my hand here it burns
when it goes in and so this is what's
happening to her so she's tensing up so
she's tensing up her muscles so that's
why you're seeing this large artifact
it's gonna get noisier right so just
watch it here's quite noisy but this is
actually going to be good for
pedagogical purposes because you're
going to be able to see precisely when
the drugs take effect and she starts to
become sedate and eventually lose
consciousness so I'm going to stop it in
just about another five or six seconds
here so right here
now you see those oscillations there see
now how they become flat the noise has
disappeared and if you look at each of
the vertical lines each vertical line is
a second so between each vertical line
you see the oscillations go up and down
about twelve to sixteen times a second
this is what we call a beta oscillation
and if I were hoping to if I were
planning to anesthetize her so that she
would have to give her anesthesia for
let's say a colonoscopy or just the
procedure that needed sedation this is
how I would I would Dow the propofol
until I saw these oscillations I would
just hold the dose there but she's
passing right through this I'm just
going to play this a little bit further
now watch what happens next you're gonna
see large look at this large slow
oscillations right that's her brain stem
becoming an activated just like in slow
way of sleep the brainstem is most
inactivated that's the deepest stage of
sleep and now you're gonna see a
transition into another stage where it's
flat and now burst flat and then burst
so this is a very profound state of coma
so she's profoundly unconscious
beginning first when you when you saw
those slow oscillations appear so let me
just go through what I've shown you here
so this is her awake at a you see she
has very small amplitude oscillations
and then she went to this sedative state
where we saw the beta oscillations and
then we went down to here to this state
II where you saw these slow oscillations
we refer to slow oscillations
oscillation which have a frequency of
less than one cycle per second then you
saw a burst oppression and then if you
look at the periods between the bursts
she's actually isoelectric or eg is
actually flat so these latter states
beginning from here I had one more D
going from D down to G these are
profound states of coma and these are
states in which a patient is
sufficiently unconscious in order to
have surgery and what we try to achieve
for this particular drug propofol is to
achieve the state D because there you're
sufficiently unconscious to have surgery
but you're you're sufficiently
unconscious but not too unconscious so
we try to dose the drugs to that
target I want to make there's there's a
final state here which is paradox like
citation which I won't say much about
but I want to make a general comment
about the oscillations and the size of
them because it's really important to
understand and it's well illustrated
here when you're awake the EEG let's say
an average young adult is around 5 micro
volts and as you go into deeper stages
of anesthesia you can see the
oscillations get to be larger for
example like in States D and E they're
there about 20 to maybe 50 micro volts
the amplitudes are and in order for this
to occur you have to get large numbers
of neurons doing almost exactly the same
thing kind of in unison so you can get
this sense of how much this is an act
this is a situation where the drugs are
taking over the circuits in the brain
and basically driving them or let me say
this another way the EEG under
anesthesia is the strongest signal to
noise ratio for any application of the
EEG and that includes sleep whether it's
the study meditation whether it's to
diagnose coma whether it's to perform
cognitive studies and we have the
strongest signal coming out of the brain
the EEG signal coming out of the brain
but ironically we make less use of it
than any other subspecialty and that's
something which we're trying to change
now and are in practice across the
across the country right so I'm gonna
display these EEG Zsasz spectrograms
here and this is an illustration of this
on the on the y-axis what you have here
is excuse me on the x-axis what you have
here is time on the y-axis you have
frequency and then the color code is
basically coming out at you the darker
the color excuse me the red the more red
the color the higher the amplitude and
if you look above here you see at the
beginning so this is the spectrogram
over time about 40 minutes of a young
woman I took care of who was having a
small procedure and we needed to just
sedate her for this procedure so I gave
her a bolus of propofol at the beginning
and then I maintained on an infusion of
propofol for about 20-25 minutes or so
and you can see that she went from
state of Si the slow oscillations there
at the beginning about six or eight
seconds and then she broke into it about
about eight or nine seconds she broke
into a pattern that shows the slow
oscillations along with the slow and
alpha oscillations so the Alpha
oscillations are roughly between eight
to 12 cycles per second we're going to
talk a lot about them so this is what
you see here now this picture here that
has a very strong red stripe at 10
cycles per second and a strong red
stripe going from about 0.1 to 4 cycles
per second this is the standard
signature for propofol and then when we
turn the drugs off somewhere around
about 27 28 minutes you can see the
oscillations fade and she woke up over
there about 30 to 32 minutes so this is
a standard signature of propofol the
induction in the beginning the slow
oscillations the maintenance with the
slow and alph oscillations and then the
recovery at around 32 minutes or so
right so these are the people that I've
had the good fortune to do this work
with Patrick burden my colleague at Mass
General Hospital
Nancy Capel a very well known
distinguished mathematician at Boston
University Shannon King who is now at
the University at Washington University
in Seattle a modest Gandhara our
collaborator at Mass General Hospital
neurosurgeon Erik Pierce
anesthesiologist at Mass General
Hospital Laura Lewis who is one of our
PhD students who's now in the faculty at
Harvard Medical School in the Martinez
Imaging Center and Sid cash who's in the
neurology department a sternal hospital
right so before I go into a few more
particulars I want to show you another
bit of phenomenology then we'll talk
we'll talk mechanisms so we've done a
number of studies in humans as well as
in non-human primates as well as in
rodents to characterize the state of
anesthesia and this is a this is a
display based on one of the human
studies we did we record whole head EEG
and volunteers who let us give them
anesthesia through increasing doses and
then decreasing doses over a period in
about two hours or so and we took
advantage of something which has been
known for years two factoids
so it's been known for about thirty
forty years now but forty years now that
there's an oscillation that starts in
the back of the head and moves forward
when someone becomes anesthetized so if
you take that ten Hertz oscillation and
that I showed you in the in the previous
slide and the two previous slides ago it
actually starts in the back of the head
if someone has his his his or her eyes
closed and they it moves forward and
concentrates in the front and then it
moves backwards and this phenomenon is
called a interiorization it was
discovered by John Mitchell Felder and
John tinker back in the late 70s that
they're both at Mayo Clinic at the time
they they showed this in studies and
non-human primates so what we do is so
that's the first factoid then there's a
second factoid which is if you just
stand here now and you close your eyes
like this and I put electrodes in the
back of your head I can measure a 10
Hertz alpha oscillation pretty much
everybody has it perhaps five to ten
percent of people don't we tend to lose
it as we get older but it's it's very
very robust it's a very robust finding
so what we do is we ask our study
subjects to close their eyes and then
what I'm showing you here are 44 sites
on the on the head so up at the top
there that's up that's the the that's
the sensor sitting up here around the
the forehead the far left is the sensors
by the left ear the far right is the EEG
electrodes or sensors by the right ear
and the two in the back are the two
which are here at the occiput at the
back of the head and this is a this is a
this is a male subject so he has his
eyes closed so you can see the two red
stripes in the back there if you count
up 0 10 20 he has a 10 Hertz oscillation
which you can see at these two sites in
the back of his head now if you look up
at the up of the upper left corner here
you see it says baseline so this is him
just lying there so he's showing you
this 10 Hertz oscillation which pretty
much everybody has right so now what
we're going to do is we're going to
start giving an increasing dose of
propofol the doses are going to increase
about every 14 minutes and you're going
to watch this oscillation move from the
back of the head to the front
it'll concentrate in the front and be
highly concentrated in the front at the
highest dose then we turn the drug off
its going to move backwards so I'll play
the video here for you so start it so
now the drug you see level 1 the
infusion is started and now you see it's
breaking up in the back and see how it
appears very very robustly in the front
there and here what I'll do is I'll just
stop it right here and this isn't even
the highest level yet this is level 4
you can see the you can see the 10 Hertz
oscillation is now in the front it
disappeared entirely in the back back
there all you see is slow oscillations
in the back and this goes from about the
centre of the head out to the front of
the head this 10 Hertz oscillation and
if I continue to play this forward so
now five is the deepest level in each
levels 14 minutes so you can see that
the deepest level now we turn the drug
off and now the oscillation moves to the
back alright and it's returned and you
and the patient wakes up there's a study
subject wakes up so I showed you what
happens I explained the Alpha
oscillation but when we looked at the
spectrogram of the young woman under
anesthesia we saw slow oscillations also
so let me tell you what's happening with
the slow oscillation their dynamics are
quite different from those of the Alpha
oscillation and this is I think one of
the best illustrations of what's
happening with the slow oscillation
these are electrophysiological
recordings made from human made from
humans so these are patients who've come
for epilepsy surgery and they get
electrodes implanted in their brains
near where the neurosurgeon and
neurologists think that the epileptic
foci are so they're implanted in one
surgery they stay in the hospital for a
period of 5 to 7 days off medications
once they've seized enough so that
they get a sense of where the the the
seizure fossa are they then bring the
patients back the operating room they
remove the electrodes and in a second a
second visit the operating room they
then perform the resection so these are
recordings from neurons in the human
brain and also neural feel potentials
from neurons recorded from circuits in
the human brain and if you look on the
left here what you see is what it looks
like when someone's conscious right and
you can see if you look down in the
bottom row there you see the neural
activity you can see that the neural
activity pretty much occurs wherever you
want me and the oscillations are of
smallish amplitude now after the person
lost consciousness you see a dramatic
change so there three features I just
want to draw your attention to first of
all look at the large slow oscillations
there across all three electrodes the
red blue and the green and they
correspond to the locations there on the
side of the brain just off of the
temporal lobe there and if you look at
where the neurons are now spiking if you
see on the left they could spike pretty
much wherever they wanted to now on the
right
they're only spiking at the minimum in
this case these are the neurons which
are near the location of the red
electrode they're only spiking near the
minimum of that oscillation and so they
have the oscillations or excuse me the
spiking activity is now gated it can
only occur at certain times so imagine
that this is occurring the same way
across the little Cal's of all the slow
oscillations and see the slow
oscillations unlike the outfall
solutions which are in sync with each
other across you know the various parts
of the brain the slow oscillations are
entirely out of sync so this is
represents like fragmentation of the
cortex in other words for the red
neurons in the red location to
communicate with the ones in the blue
location they have a very narrow phase
when the where they can do it however if
they want to communicate with the
neurons in the green location that's
going to be very very difficult to do
because they emit spikes
different times so we think that this is
one of the mechanisms through which the
anesthetics are driving the brain into a
state of unconsciousness because it's
impeding its ability to communicate
wherever it wants to so so why is this
important
what why would we care excuse me why
would we care about this well here's why
so what most frequently happens is that
I get requests and journalists to talk
about awareness under anesthesia at I'm
a case of mind perhaps where I had a
patient who was aware under anesthesia
and I didn't realize it and they find
that exciting because it makes
anesthesia mysterious it makes it you
know who and it and it makes it seem
like there's something that we can't
quite understand and nothing could be
further from the truth first of all
awareness under anesthesia is not a
public health menace
it occurs in 1 to 1 to 2 Oh so 1 to
10,000 to let's say 1 to 20,000 cases
it's a fairly rare occurrence however
when it does occur gets a lot of press
and recently there's been a lot of
discussion about this in the popular
press because of a book that was just
released by Kate Colle Adams a writer
from Australia and what she discusses
the whole phenomenon of anesthesia in
terms of awareness I mean that's the
focal point of the entire book a
principle the entire book and what we
know now is that there's no reason for
awareness to occur so I've gone back to
the slide here where I'm showing you the
spectrogram so if someone came to me and
said Emory the last time I had surgery I
had awareness I say it's not gonna
happen this time so here's one way I
would prevent it I would dial them down
I'd administer propofol until I saw the
Alpha oscillations and slow oscillations
and if anything that I've said up until
now is correct that the Alpha
oscillations represent the thalamus and
cortex tied up the slow oscillations
represent this very broad cortical
fragmentation it's gonna be extremely
difficult for someone to be conscious
during those states so that's a solved
20 2018 the reason it might not be
practically a solved problem is that
most anesthesiologists don't use the EEG
the way I'm describing it here to take
care of patients when they're
administering anesthesia so the risk for
the awareness remains but the way to
prevent it is very very clear so I just
wanted to put this in here to say that
I've shown you that the oscillations
let's say like the slow oscillations are
associated with the production are
associated the state of unconsciousness
but you might ask if I were to produce
though oscillations what I see let's say
an animal becoming unconscious and this
is an experiment which we did a few
years ago it's part of the work done by
Laura Lewis and her PhD thesis in which
she put off the genetic probes into the
NA there you can see they're placed into
the reticular nucleus of the thalamus
which is this large inhibitory network
around the thalamus and what she's doing
is optically genetically opted without
the genetics stimulating these
inhibitory neurons there and getting
them to shut down essentially the
outflow of information going through
specific parts of the thalamus and if
you look over here in B you see that
when the laser is turned on at 0 C
there's no power than all of a sudden
when the laser is turned on you get this
large slow oscillation and if you look
down in d you can see exactly the same
thing and when the laser comes on you go
from this sort of high frequency
oscillation to the large slow
oscillation and the part which isn't
apparent from these diagrams here is
that with this you see a decrease in
arouse on the animal suggesting that not
only is this R the slow oscillations at
least associated with a decreased level
of arousal but inducing them could
probably be a mechanism for decreasing
arousal and again I just draw the
analogy here to slow wave sleep the
deepest stage of sleep when the brain is
most with the brainstem is most
inactivated is during slow-wave sleep so
these slow waves are likely a causal
mechanism through which the
statics are inducing loss of juicing
unconsciousness right so this is what I
just told you why does propofol make you
unconscious the Alpha oscillations and
the slow us the slow wave oscillations
the alpha oscillation is tying up the
thalamus and cortex to slow oscillations
fragmenting the cortex I showed you this
anterior ization this movement of the
oscillations these lost the alpha
oscillations from the back to the front
and this may be one of the mechanisms
contributing to this notion of frontal
parietal disconnection of thisis as to
how anesthetics are acting on neural
circuits and I've given you a sense of
what happens in the in the brainstem by
talking about the slow oscillations in
particular so I need to make this point
here because it's important to
understand and it's the general
anesthesia is not sleep and if you look
down here on the left you know these are
the various stages of anesthesia which
I've shown you before and if you look
over on the right these are the various
stages of sleep and remember sleep is
two is basically a phenomenon so natural
physiologic phenomenon where you go
roughly every 90 minutes between a non
REM state which has three phases and
then a REM state so you go non-rem Rim
non REM REM you do that every 90 minutes
for about four to six times a night and
you typically awake from the REM state
whereas if you look at anesthesia you
see her on the left we give you a drug
and we hold you in this state so you
have this very fixed oscillatory
dynamics which you've which I've just
shown you and they stay there for the
entire time that the drug is running and
they dissipate when we turn the infusion
off so you can basically see why general
anesthesia is not sleep now when we talk
to patients we typically say mr. Jones
gonna have you go off to sleep for your
surgery one of the reasons we do that is
I can't go to them and say excuse me mr.
Jones going to put you in a drug-induced
reversible coma because that wouldn't
endear me to my patient however what I
can do and what I do actually do when
I'm talking to my patient is say I'm
going to put you in a state of general
anesthesia what that means is you're
going to be unconscious you won't be
able to remember you won't feel any pain
you won't be moving
I will take very good care of your to
watch over your breathing your heart
rate your blood pressure and I'll make
sure that that your that we you know we
bring you out of the state when we
finish so what I've done is as opposed
to saying sleep which it isn't
I just basically just I give the patient
the definition of anesthesia and what
you find is patients get that they
understand that and but I wanted to
point this out to have you appreciate
that general anesthesia is definitely
not sleep and and as a further point on
that the sleeping medications which are
currently sold you know over-the-counter
or even the ones which you might get via
prescription there's no way in the world
they could actually induce rim non REM
what they can do is if you think of them
as mild you think of them as sedatives
or maybe very very weak anesthetics
that's a very that's a much better
conceptual idea of what they're doing
they put you in a state of sedation and
then the idea is there hopefully they
will then allow you your natural sleep
mechanisms to take over but there's no
way in the world a single drug can make
sure you do this go between the states
of REM and non-rem sleep and I think
that's very important for us to
appreciate that what we're getting is
not a state of sleep from these drugs
but a state of sedation which is very
much akin to a week a week effect of an
anesthetic so I goat so they're
generalizations that follow from this I
could take any one of the drugs propofol
sevoflurane ketamine Dex meta tamo D and
if I look at them this way we can see
that they have different dynamics
however if I look at their spectra we
can see that their spectra are quite
different so this allows us to
appreciate the differences in the drugs
as if by looking at their spectra and
these differences in their spectral
displays follow differences in the
mechanism through which they work in the
brain and I wanted to point to see the
fluorine in particular because it is a
modern-day ether and propofol which
we've talked about down the lower left
there is ketamine and on the right is
Dex meta tamo diene and what we can do
is each anesthetic has a different
signature that relates to its different
mechanism action in the brain on the
central nervous system
and we can map out that circuitry and we
can now relate those dynamics directly
to the circuits in the brain where we
and the receptors of which the drugs are
acting so we can do a deep dive and each
one of these other drugs the same we've
done a deep dive here into propofol
alright so I want to tell you a little
bit about aging now so this is work
which I've had the good fortune to do
with my colleagues at Children's
Hospital dr. Laura Cornelison and dr.
Chuck Bertie
dr. Sienna kgo is one of my colleagues
at Mass General Hospital dr. perdón who
I mentioned earlier and dr. Kim was one
of our postdocs who is now back in Korea
so this is propofol so this is a thirty
year old man who was receiving a
propofol infusion right you can see the
Alpha oscillation of the slow Delta
oscillation this is someone who's 57
receiving an also an infusion of
propofol you can see the Alpha
oscillations of slow oscillation maybe
the Alpha oscillations little fainter
practice at a slightly lower frequency a
little bit below 10 Hertz but it's still
there here's an 81 year old woman right
this was a woman I took care of a few
years ago she had a tumor on her chest
the size of an American football and it
took the nurse it took the thoracic
surgeons the better part of six hours to
remove it if you look at the
oscillations you see there you can see
she has 10 Hertz oscillations there
they're at a much weaker amplitude than
those of the 57 year old and certainly
the 30 year old and if you look at all
the higher frequencies it's all blue
meaning that there's very little
oscillatory activity there when she's
under propofol and this is very typical
as we get older we see that the
oscillations diminish in amplitude the
good thing about my using the EEG here
was that I was able to give her a
fraction of the already age adjusted
dose and know that she was well
anesthetized or sufficiently unconscious
in this particular case so that I didn't
have to give her more and I was able to
wake her up immediately following the
procedure this is one of the advantages
of using the EEG that I'm reading the
that I'm reading the dynamics of what I
see as I take care of the patient now
here's the part that's a little bit
sobering
so the two gentlemen they're the one on
the left and one in the center roughly
the same age the gentleman on the left
EEG looks like the that of the 30 year
old and the one in the middle looks like
that of the 81 year old you know we age
different physically it makes sense that
our brains may age differently as well
but what's wild is that you'd be able to
see it under anesthesia so here's one
way of thinking about this if you forget
about anesthesia for the purposes of
putting someone in a state where they
could tolerate having surgery and think
of it more as an experiment I'm going to
put in a stimulus I'm going to measure
the response and the stimulus is the
drug and the response is going to be the
oscillatory dynamics generated by the
brain well what's going to happen so
when you're young you put in the drug
you put in the propofol in this
particular case you get oscillations
looks like this as you get older the
oscillations get to be weaker or and
have lower amplitude now why is this
well we don't have to invoke any
concepts of like Alzheimer's or dementia
I mean just think about it there are 10
to the 10 neurons in the brain they've
been around pretty much as long as the
person has been alive and over time each
neuron is just getting older so if you
think about the dynamics the myelin
sheath breaks down so the insulation the
cell volume declines the dendrites are
no longer is dynamic that and extending
it retract as much we produce less
neurotransmitter and the cell is much
more the neuron is much more susceptible
to oxidative stress so you have a
machine whose units are older so that
the ability to generate those dynamics
just declines with time what's wild is
that you can get some sense of this
basically under anesthesia and you can
just predict now what the kids would
look like so this is a three-year-old
and here is now a 14 year old you can
see they have exactly the same dynamics
but what's occurring is is that they're
there they're evolving with time the
oscillations get to be much they decline
in amplitude in fact here's a better
depiction of it you can see that
with age the oscillations reach a peak
somewhere around maybe six to eight
years of age and then decline from there
afterwards and the 81 year old would be
over to the far far right you know
basically like off the scale and if you
look at the very young brain if you look
at the brains of neonates let's say
three months zero to three months of age
and four to six months of age the zero
to three months of age under anesthesia
show essentially just slow oscillations
the alpha oscillation doesn't appear
until about four months of age and
what's interesting is is that when it
appears it's not dynamic the dynamics
that I showed you the movement the
anterior ization doesn't occur until the
kids are somewhere around a year perhaps
fourteen months of age and this is
consistent with this idea that what's
probably happening is is that they're
not sufficient the Lama cortical
connections for the Alpha oscillation to
be produced that's why we don't see it
in the 0 to 3 month olds but they're
they're sufficiently present in the four
to six month old so we actually see this
is alpha oscillation dynamics and so
this is just really a window into brain
development again if you think about
what happens is you have these changes
in excitation and abyssion that occur
with time as we move through critical
periods with the brain developing it
makes sense that this would be manifest
with the administration of anesthetics
in terms of the ability to produce or
not be able to produce certain dynamics
and in particular with the with the
thalamic cortical connections as I'm
showing over here on the right the they
are aided their formation is aided by
what are called sub plate neurons the
sub plate neurons are like in the early
that you know sort of the early the
young brain and the active sort of
Usher's they guide the connections from
the thalamus going up to the cortex and
then they sort of they pull away so they
help hook the cyst
they help wire the thalamus and cortex
and what it says is that that wiring is
not sufficiently complete in order to
produce these alpha oscillations that
would be consistent with our idea and
however there's sufficient completing of
this wiring by the time you're about
four my child is about four to six
months of age so you actually see these
you see these dynamics so again
anesthesia being a little window into
brain development so let me just leave
you with this final idea of reanimation
so this is my colleague Ken salt and
below who's been working on this problem
and so below I have a quote from a
letter to the editor that was written
regarding an article that appeared about
our group in the New York Times back in
2011 and the letter said I had my first
corrective surgery due to infantile
paralysis in 1949 the bill from the
anesthesiologist was $400 my mother was
horrified but my father calmed her when
he said it was probably $50 for the
procedure but I gladly I gladly pay the
other 350 because he knew how to wake
her up right as I often say as
anesthesiologist you don't pay us to to
anesthetize you to put you to sleep you
pay us to wake you up
and so that's what ken has been working
on very very assiduously here for the
last several years and so this is an one
of the rat volunteers in his laboratory
who's in this chamber where he's been
anesthetized for the last 20 minutes or
so with ISO flooring again this is one
of the ethers so he has an intravenous
line in his tail vein and what Ken is
gonna do is he's gonna inject Riddle in
the same ritalin which is used to treat
kids who have ADHD so now he's gonna
hook up a syringe and flush it in now
watch what happens now we didn't turn
the anesthesia off right we didn't turn
it off and and you can see the animals
coming to store you starting to move
he's changing his something induced the
change and stayed in him and now he has
to turn over for this to count it
doesn't count if he doesn't turn over so
there he does he's moving
moving and he does make it I've seen the
end of the video he does eventually flip
here we go
one Cohen did you can do it one more
come on heave-ho here old college try
boom he made it okay great now so before
I tell you about the mechanisms of this
let me talk about what I call the
science what I call signs from the word
on the street so this was an article
that was in the New York Times back in
2015 and was about the use of or the
abuse of ADHD drugs these stimulants
that are used to treat ADHD ADHD and
it's the story of this it starts off of
the story this woman who has startup
company and she receives information
from her investors that basically tell
her that they need a new financial plan
on their desk first thing in the morning
and I have with the one she sent in so
she texts her dealer he comes up to her
apartment about 11:00 p.m. and he she
gives him a lot of money and he then
gives her a bag of pills she takes one
of the pills and she considers taking
another one and then you see there she
says no she says I several minutes later
she felt her brain snapped to attention
and so this is actually what and so what
what she didn't did was she worked from
midnight to 7:00 a.m. slept for two
hours and then delivered the new
financial report to the investors so
this is a common phenomenon now where
people in stride stress jobs and let me
just be clear this makes no sense it's
very dangerous people should not do this
right but she's using these drugs to
actually stimulate her circuits and help
her think better and so if anesthesia
has disrupted your circuits perhaps a
very appropriate clinical time to
administer drugs like this is when to
help people come out of anesthesia so
you can help their circuits work better
and help restore their ability to think
more concretely or more clearly so this
is so this is what I call science from
the word on the street the word on the
street says that we should use this more
we should use this in taking care of
patients who are having anesthesia care
right so let me just show you this all
right I want to show you an application
of this idea all right
so what Ken has done he's actually
studied the ability of like what state
is the end when there when the rat comes
back you know when he came back you know
could he actually perform a task or was
he just sort of still stumbling around
and maybe not functional so he did the
study this time anesthetized the animal
instead of giving him intravenous
ritalin to wake him up what he does is
he stimulates his ventral tegmental area
this area which is very important for
cognition and also for reward so he
stimulates the ventral to cognate
tegmental area and what we're going to
show you is is that when he stimulates
this area even though the anesthesia is
on the animals gonna come too and he's
gonna start working so this animals been
trained to go from left to right and he
starts on the left excuse me he goes to
the right and he'll he has to execute a
task he has to touch the correct figure
and if he touches the correct figure he
can turn around and get a food reward
and he'll do this he's been trained to
do this so when he wakes up from the
anesthesia he realized this is what he's
supposed to do he realizes where he is
so this will happen as long as we have
the stimulation on then we turn the
stimulation off he actually goes back to
being anesthetized so I'll start this
here right
so the stimulation is off
he's anesthetized so now what we do is
Ken turns the stimulation on he wakes up
and I remember we didn't turn the
anesthesia off we just stimulated his
ventral tegmental area so he looks for a
reward but there's no free lunch so he
has to go execute the task so now I
guess he gets a reward so the
stimulation is on can change the 20
Hertz from 40 Hertz so he does it again
turns around little floppy but he's
executing the task and now he turns
around again I think this time he gets
it wrong so he gets it incorrect this
time right and the light tells me he got
it incorrect and now he's gonna turn
around again right the the lights the
two symbols come on and now Ken turns
off the stimulation and I see the
anesthesia takes over again all right so
what's happening here so when you're
administering or in kenan´s
administering Ritalin he's increasing
the release of dopamine in this very
important pathway going from the ventral
tegmental area there at the top of the
brainstem going all the way up to the
limbic system up into the cortex and
this pathway is important for reward but
it's also important for cognition so
this is this pathway that's being
activated by in this case the you know
the startup company executive when she's
taking her Ritalin that she gets from
her from her pusher all right and so the
idea is that if it's helpful there it
should be helpful as I said before and
helping people wake up from anesthesia
you could do it by administering ritalin
in trevean or orally in that case or by
stimulating this area directly that's
what Ken was just doing so what we're
showing you in this last video is that
all times there's a balance between
being inhibition X and excitation in the
brain when we're awake there's more
excitation under anesthesia it's more in
addition and so then what Ken is doing
is he's not
blocking the effect of the anesthetic
directly what he's doing is he's driving
an excitatory pathway that overcomes
essentially the inhibition right now
when we do this in the case of someone
waking up from anesthesia we all have
you turn the anesthetics off and you
also use that to enhance the excitatory
effect of administering like the Ritalin
we just kept the anesthesia going here
in these cases just to show you how
strong the excitatory effect is right so
this is something that Ken is now has in
Phase two clinical trial testing ritalin
as a way to wake patients up from from
general anesthesia all right so this is
what I've told you the brain and general
anesthesia is dynamic it's not turned
off we think that one of the primary
ways in which the drugs work is by
creating and sustaining these
oscillations and these are one of the
mechanisms as I said these are one of
the mechanisms to which these altered
states of arousal are produced in
particular in consciousness it provides
a very clear robust strategy for monitor
and the brain under anesthesia because
as I said the EEG under anesthesia is
the largest signal to noise ratio
phenomena for anything for which the EEG
is used we've shown you how the EEG
changes systematic with age and also
with anesthetic and we just showed you
what how you could turn the brain back
on after anesthesia and suggest that
this might be a way of not only speeding
recovery but reducing brain dysfunction
after anesthesia and as I said earlier
we're not only learning about anesthesia
but we're learning things about the
brain for example the idea that you'd
have different dynamics sort of EEG
dynamics as a function of age is
something which is really obvious now in
retrospect but you know wouldn't have
predicted how do we not studied the you
know the anesthetized brain across
different age groups and now we can
think about how very directly how that
relates to brain development and they're
very young and brain aging in the and
the elderly and so this is sort of like
the anesthesiologist view of clinical
neuroscience and I'll just leave you
with this idea you know we sit sort of
here in the middle if you would you know
general anesthesia and all these other
problems are
topics in clinical neuroscience sort of
circle around us I'll just give an
example so ketamine is a drug which is
used to treat pain but it's also a drug
which is used to study as a model for
schizophrenia and now it's being
administered in low-dose as a way to
treat depression and you realize that
the opioid epidemic is a problem that is
rampant in the United States right now
and if you we use high dose opioids in
certain setting strictly in cardiac
surgery so one way of thinking about the
states of these patients are NDErs
they've actually put themselves in a
very profound state of general
anesthesia where they're likely to stop
breathing so the idea is that we use to
take care of patients who for anesthesia
it could be brought to bear and helping
to treat patients who have had opioid
overdoses or if you look at epilepsy
there's a drug methohexital which it
load those can be used to induce an
epileptic seizure
whereas in high doses it can be used to
like arrest an epileptic seizure so I
think that by taking a neuroscience
approach the study of general anesthesia
we do two things we make it possible to
really understand how the drugs are
creating these various states and to
prove and to propose and design new and
better ways of generating the state
monitoring patients who are receiving
anesthesia but also we open up this
whole what I would consider this as I
was always saying earlier this untapped
approach to studying the brain from a
perspective which is highly informative
the konex as I'm suggesting here with
this diagram to a lot of areas in in
neuroscience so I'll stop there thank
you very much